Freunde herzlich willkommen zu diesem
Video wir befinden uns auf dem Rückweg
aus Berlin und man muss auch mal Stopp
machen auf so einer Reise normalerweise
sind solche Raststätten na ja nicht das
Gelbe vom Ei diese Raststätte die wir
heute besuchen soll die beste in ganz
Deutschland sein und von außen sieht
schon mal ganz anders aus als man das
kennt
[Musik]
ein amerikanisches Diner direkt bei
Berlin draußen ist Werbung für Burger
keine Ahnung was wir bekommen ich habe
nur gelesen es war super sein
anscheinend frühstücken
sechs Speisen bestellt warum habe ich
auch alles als Minions
weil ich bin vegan 2020 hat sogar noch
mal ein Portal darüber geschrieben aber
zwei zwölf haben die auf jeden Fall die
Auszeichnung gewonnen ja wir haben
wirklich gemacht
2012 gut war kann auch heute immer noch
genauso gut sein vielleicht müssen wir
selbst auch die raststättentester werden
und die beste küren das so lange
Autofahrt muss man ja so irgendwas essen
ja zu kommen und das muss das jetzt uns
geben genau das muss machen und nicht
mehr nicht weniger ich meine die
Konkurrenz ist groß so ne an vielen
großen Raststätten halt die großen
Burger King was auch immer deshalb bin
ich gespannt wie sich das abgeht muss so
gut sein finde ich dass Leute in Umweg
fahren um mir hinzukommen das darf man
erwarten von also was darf man selbst
von der besten Raststätte erraten
danke schön
ja die sehen außergewöhnlich aus danke
schön erster Eindruck ihr habt jetzt die
Gerichte gesehen es sieht alles es sieht
aus wie verarschstätte aber sowas hier
zum Beispiel ey das ist übelst weich das
Brötchen also vielleicht schlummert
darin mehr als man erwartet ich meine
eigentlich muss man sagen das
konkurriert ein Stück weit eigentlich
mit Burger King und McDonald's weil das
ist der Stopp den man häufig macht wenn
man auf der Autobahn fährt und wenn es
besser ist als Burger King oder
McDonald's dann ist es schon gut wir
schreiben gerade merklich unsere
Anforderungen ein bisschen runter aber
weg
legen wir los mit dem Cheeseburger und
ich finde wirklich der sieht ehrlich aus
sieht aus wie ein ehrlicher Cheeseburger
Brötchen schön angeröstet angetoastet
Ketchup oben rote Zwiebeln Tomatensalat
schmolzener Käse und das Petty sieht
interessant aus gehen wir mal rein in
die Masse
saftig ist er alle Male Burger schmeckt
Fisch was Frisches von der Autobahn zu
essen sehr selten das Band ist sogar
wirklich geil also diese Körner und so
das kennt man sogar nicht Käse
zerschmilzt gut hat und die Soße ist
auch sehr sehr nice die große Sache an
der man schrauben könnt ist das Petty
weil wenn wir mal reinschauen so das ist
natürlich komplett durchgebraten da kann
man durch was dran machen aber ich
verstehe komplett warum Leute diese
Raststätte mögen jetzt hier rein ist das
und ich finde der Preis jetzt
12,99 € mit Pommes und Getränke
für eine Raststätte bevor ich in Köln
gewohnt habe habe ich in Aschaffenburg
gewonnen in Unterfangen Bayern ich habe
80.000 Einwohner und das ist auf jeden
Fall besser als jeder Burger den man
sich da liefern lassen kann um auch zu
dieser schießtrip und so das ist schon
so der ist sehr Soße stimmt
der ist auch besser als der aussieht ne
der ist wirklich nicht verkehrt ich
meine wir haben halt gestern
viel weniger erwartet
warum muss man sagen Alter wenn du hast
einen schönen fleischigen Geschmack also
ich glaube das dass er dir mehr gibt als
du brauchen Prozent 1000%. ja wir haben
jetzt ein bisschen real Reihenfolge
gewählt weil wir kriegen jetzt gleich
nach dem Burger und im Schnitzel die
perfekt ab zum Monats Burger weil das
finde ich es auch wild das zeigt auch
eine Passion das ist monatlich eine neue
Eigenkreation gibt von einem Burger der
gewechselt wird sieht sehr nach Crispy
Chicken Patty aus dass man von Burger
King vielleicht kennt wir haben aber
Ananas drauf ist jetzt schon
wahrscheinlich nicht jedermanns Sache
ich hatte aber mal diesen dicker Burger
bei einem Körner Burgerladen stellte war
sehr lecker guck mal diese diese Front
an der ist auch schon der ist noch mal
deutlich größer und mächtiger aber
Attacke
so eine Cocktailsauce auch drauf ne aber
wirklich auch dieser Burger Crispy
Chicken Patty ist eigentlich identisch
zu dem was man so von Burger King kennt
so ich mag das sehr gerne bis jetzt auch
nicht und das dürfen auch nicht erwarten
so dass ihr selbst gewollt selbst
paniert selbst irgendwas macht wird aber
der ist auch lecker dieser Burger der
ist ja hier auf dem Kanal immer bei so
den besten Sachen so in dem Gebiet dem
besten Burger die beste Pasta und so
weiter ne zwischen den ganzen besten
[Gelächter]
man merkt dass du die Leute so hier ein
bisschen Herzblut reinstecken man ist
auch nicht schlecht ne also ich glaube
viele viele Leute würden das mögen wenn
die Heizung
möglichst richtig gut
ja bitte komm wir gehen gemeinsam schöne
Kruste also das schmeckt auch stabil
also was sagst du zum Schnitzel auch das
super knusprige Panade egal was es ist
nicht das Beste das beste der Welt aber
seit besserem mit Herz
boah auf jeden Fall eine geile Schärfe
ein Teil von mir liebt das hier gerade
ne so dieses deiner dieses amerikanische
Essen American breakfast Pancakes so ich
kann keine Ahnung habe irgendwie vor
allem auch so als ich so 14 15 16 war
Amerika so krank romantisiert ich habe
das paar Mal erzählt ich habe immer so
geträumt im Unterricht weil auf einer
Seite in unserem Englischbuch war so ein
Pancake starten
richtig geiler starte Pancakes darauf
oben so ein Block Butter Blaubeeren
Ahornsirup der 15-Jährige Max der da
geträumt hat der ist gerade froh dass er
fühlt sich heute einen Traum irgendwie
einfach die ganze Karte bestellt
knuspriger resti auch kein klassisches
Raststätten Essen gar nicht das sieht
für mich auch aus wie so ein
truckerfrühstück oder das ist so und
dann kannst du bis nach Australien
fahren oder mit einer Tankfüllung
wenn ich genau das ne wirklich in
Amerika in einem deiner gegessen hätte
ich würde es total feiern knusprig
scrumble Ex das ist so konnte
[Gelächter]
formuliert sich was in mir wisst ihr was
wir machen einfach das Fazit machen wir
wenn wir ein bisschen unterwegs gewesen
sind so nach zwei Stunden
Gedanken machen dann melde ich mich noch
mal
also nicht so ultra fluffig sind eher so
flap ja
wirklich sind halt so
in Deutsch
sein
also das ist jetzt schon grob hier ne
also dann werden
ne die sind sehr gut okay
in New York wird zu auch mal so ein
Pancake bekommen überall auf der Welt
kriegt man bestimmt so mal ein Pancake
aber es gab auch da ist er dann nicht
gut ja genau
eine sehr interessante Erfahrung alle
Male also ich sag mal so wenn ihr mal
Langeweile habt hier vorbei kommt Fahrt
auf jeden Fall raus das auf jeden Fall
aber zum Essen zu allem melden wir uns
gleich noch mal wieder also zwei drei
Stunden später ich fand zwar ein geiler
Stopp so das ist glaube ich auch das
allerwichtigste ähm es war also vor
allem voran war das Personal super nett
es war sehr sauber das Essen war ein Eis
es war auch eine außergewöhnlich schöne
Raststätte also ich persönlich fand es
schön und keine Ahnung also es hat mir
jetzt nicht irgendwie so mehr
kulinarisch irgendwie die Augen geöffnet
aber damit hätte man auch nicht rechnen
dürfen deshalb etwas anderes Video ich
hoffe es hat euch trotzdem gefallen ihr
könnt ja mal in die Kommentare schreiben
ob euch diese Raststätte geflasht hat ob
wir das krass cool findet oder ich denke
okay es ist
jetzt nicht so besonders ne schreibt das
mal in die Kommentare der nächste Woche
Donnerstag kommt endlich Berlin ich
freue mich sehr darauf ihr könnt euch
auch freuen bis dahin ciao
[Musik]